this is exciting i'm really excited to
be here
here at the ntc with all of you but also
i'm super excited for the first time in
oslo i had yesterday with friends of
mine a lot of bruno's it's delicious
but of course you didn't came here to
to listen to me
praise the norwegian cuisine you hear
about learning what i learned about
source generators in wasteland
so
my name is stefan pertz
i started develop coding in 2008.
i'm originally from austria
i started my first t-sharp application
in 2012. i did unity back then so this
was mono i then switched to dot net in
2013 when i moved to germany
the germans they really taught me how to
do.net in c-sharp it was excellent
experience
and i learned also all the predecessors
to source code generation via roslin for
example d4 templates
actually didn't do foldy
il weaving via 40 however i did check
out post sharp
and also reflection emit
and creating expression trees
and
source generators are now the latest
addition on how you can generate code
at compile time so that is fast at one
time
i
into in last year i've started actually
with rosslyn the and the western api is
very exhaustive i think now i'm not one
and a half years into it and i believe i
know five percent is a beast
and doing source generators now i
started this year half a year ago
actually after listening uh to another
talk which which inspired me and social
media is awesome
currently i'm in austria working as a
senior developed by admiral
schwartzbergen in vienna
and i listed here some of my alter egos
if you want to connect and tell me about
the talk what was good what was bad
maybe you have some questions i would
like to connect
so what are we gonna talk about tonight
so
c-sharp nine added two small features
which facilitate roslin generators we
will check them out then we have a look
at the laws of source generation what to
do what they can do and what they are
not supposed to do
we will check out some examples.net six
the bcl now actually ships with source
generators microsoft is building source
generators themselves
we will check out the anatomy how does
the source generator look like
what base classes are there and so on we
will see the tooling which facilitates
us developing these
bit of debugging
i i'm prepared
we will see
um there is a bit if you want to enable
more up-to-date features such as
nullable reference types there's a bit
of a
of tweak you have to do there but we
will we will see how this works we'll
talk about the different versions since
boston generators are ever evolving.6
just got new features
we will see
some performance issues that we will
also solve
we'll have a brief look how this looks
like in nougat so how we can ship our
source generators to other developers
and we'll have there will be tons of
examples and some more resources
so
c sharp nine
in c sharp nine which shipped with dot
net five
roughly last year
um
two features were added under the title
now support for source generators
previously c-sharp 8 and lower
you could have partial methods but they
must be returning void
they cannot have explicit visibility
they are always private implicitly they
cannot have out parameters
and
for example if we have a partial method
without an implementation it actually
gets stripped out of the code but now
with c sharp nine
those rules got a little bit lifted
so
since um
c-sharp is always very so
as so far very backwards compatible i
here have a
partial method
and i'm not calling it in code we see
the ide tells me this is not used so
this will actually be stripped out it
will not be in the final compilation
unless we really use it
and the old rules apply i cannot return
string this will immediately
result in an error
however if i now state an explicit
visibility perhaps internal
or any visibility now the new rules
apply and the new rules allow all that
was forbidden beforehand but we must
supply
an implementation if there is no
implementation this will cause a
compiler error this will not compile
but i now actually have a source
generator in place already which now
fills this hole so some various code
which now has the same definition and
actually returned something from this
get method so let's see what if i it
happens if i call this
let's get this string
let's run the application
and i didn't write any
there is no user code that actually
produces now the
from generator but it actually generates
producing it so it's part of the
compilation but i didn't write it
directly
another thing that got added are module
initializers
so there is a new attribute the module
initializer attribute also available in
stock.net five
and we can put the module initializer
attribute on a method which is static
somehow visible so it can't be private
nor a local function must be accessible
it must return void cannot have any old
parameters it can't be generic can take
any generic type parameters
and
this is then picked up by the compiler
and called before any other code so if
we have some static initializers they
are called after the module initializer
so we could have a module write which is
most likely assembly-wide initialization
at the beginning
so i will briefly
get my snippet here
so i have here
a text property
and i set it via the module initializer
however i never call this init method
directly
yet
if i print
this
property it says initialize what the
motor initializer sets
this is called before anything else
and those two
help
building
source generators
now what are the laws of source
generation with rustling
perhaps let's have a brief look on how
this actually looks like
so
this picture
basically shows it very well in the
beginning
now my shortcut stops working
sorry for that
in the beginning there is a compilation
which which consists entirely of the
user code
this then gets shipped
or
pushed to the source generator to any
source generated which are there they
now basically can run through all the
user code they see all the user code
however they don't see the syntax trees
of the of um package references or other
references but they could access the
semantic model behind it
and then the new generator may or may
not generate no new source this actually
strings
strings in c sharp
then get
back to the compilation and are compiled
together with the user code so if our
social media creates a compiler error
the user ends up with a compiler error
that they can't actually really fix
because it's the source generator
generating them the generated source can
be edited by the user
and the laws around that is that we do
retrieve
the user code and drift that the syntax
tree so that that's um all the nodes for
example the private
a private keyword that's uh that's
in the huge syntax tree just a note or a
method declaration and so on
um you can also grab the semantic model
which gives more information about the
actual type
and we can add new source
as strings and we can only add source
we cannot remove or manipulate source so
this is not really a replacement for for
example il weaving
this is so far
the the restriction
it can it could produce diagnostics
because it's basically technically it's
an analyzer analyzers can do diagnostics
such as reporting infos or warnings or
even errors prevent the compilation from
succeeding
and
we also may access additional files
additional files in the compilation are
for example the app to json
source changes are unordered they do
well they do one in a defined order but
it's not documented what that order is
and so that they cannot depend on each
other the output of once one source
generate is not visible to the next
generator
and yeah technically they are analyzers
so
the two most prominent use cases are
either with source generation we could
pre we could avoid having the user write
tedious implementations for example i
notify property changed that's pretty
much always looks the same it's a
certain pattern that we apply or
implementing i
equatable well
um
records are now solving that a bit
they're not source generated they're
actually a c-sharp feature a language
feature
and the second use case is we could
avoid reflection so that we can interact
with the user code and build upon it for
example
in an asp.net core application don't
find the
the the controllers via reflection but
actually find them at compile time
already so then startup gets much faster
i also linked the cookbook if you want
to check this out this is like the prime
source of
of how to power build uh source
generators
so
now let's actually get to it how does
the chelsea look like now we've dotnet
six
two source generators are shipped
we have
in system text json
and also in logging.abstractions which
saves us
writing boilerplate code but also
uh gives us a lot of performance
so
let's go with vlogging first i grab this
method here so this is this is how the
generator works
the generator analyzes my code searches
for a partial type in this case the log
type
and searches for a method a partial
method which has the logger message
attribute on it
now i define
my
my values to this
log message for example 240 as the as
the event id the log level is
information and i can do a format string
which then gets filled in by the
parameter
and this method must have a logger with
it if i remove this locker then i will
get a diagnostic so this diagnostic is
not actually from the
um
well actually the generator is now not
generating something so we missed that
implementation
we need that it doesn't have to be an
extension method it can be now we can
call that
instead of here
let's say
log dot hello
and we
need to pass actually it's an extension
method so i can say this
and we can
pass law
and there's a bunch of code
generated better generator i can
12 into these and this is generated by
the source generator we see at the top
is dude he wants us that this file is
auto generated it looks very similar and
wider there is a there is a lock on top
telling you we can't edit it doesn't
make sense because it's generated
and
so this is very similar we could also do
this manually with the logger
message.define to have the high
performance logging but it's tedious to
always write the same code so the social
media reduces that
and another use case oops
is about performance system talks system
text json so it is actually shipped with
the dotnet six
bcl
we i define here oops
i define some entity
now i define another method that gets
picked up by the generator the generator
searches for types which have json
serializable attribute applied
and also a partial deriving from json
serializer context
and i don't have any implementation but
it compiles because the
json server as a context does have an
abstract method
i do need
to implement this but it's a generator
taking over
and the usage is now such
that i
oops
can i define my entity i say json
serializer.serialize and use this new
generator type so there's the serializer
context this is my type that it defines
down there
dot default.entity and this is now
the type information that is used for
deserialization but also zero is a yeah
the other way around first serialization
and then the round track
decentralization back to the original
entity
and when we run this
we will see first the json
then the deserialized record again
we can also control this analyzer
via the source
json source generator options
we can for example i passed in true i
could also pass it oops false
so now the output string is not intended
now we just have one line
so this is what the what the the
analyzer is inspecting and a lot of code
is generated here if we uh go to
definition this is all generated by the
generator so this is the most naive
direct code that you could write to
serialize an entity no reflection so
it's a lot of code but it's
significantly faster
there is also with dotnet six ships a
source generator with
blazers so that the razer files get
source generated
so let's come to the anatomy
if i want to write this myself not just
use the generator from somebody else
we
basically
uh let me quickly check my
try to restart
zoom it
no we still didn't fix it um
[Music]
we basically
have to consume the package microsoft
dot code analysis dot c sharp
dot workspaces it's not in the system
namespace it's in the microsoft code
analysis namespace this is all
everything was then starts with
microsoft dot code analysis
and it's a source
generator available since the version
3.8
i always
like to include the code analysis
analyzers which is an analyzer packages
which scans the source generator code
that i write
and produces warnings if i don't follow
the rules for example with type equality
in roslyn
rarely any type
implements
equality via the equals operator so
there are special
comparers for that to use then we have a
type which derives from i source
generator
and we need to apply the generator
attribute this is very important
otherwise the
the tool for example visual studio or
the.net sdk will not pick it up
then we have two methods they initialize
at the execute we will come to that
white in a minute
and optionally we can use a syntax
receiver which is basically a visitor
which
calls on visit syntax node on each and
every syntax node that is found
so let's have a look at
a source generator
so
maybe you have seen the talk from david
fowler about implementation detailed
matters where he briefly shows how
how in
enum.2string
or the
enum.getname and the fast
the fastest way how to get the the
constant string representation of an
enum because there is a reflection and a
binary array lookup
involved
and a moana if implementation would be
to wide it ourself
and this is now what a source tuner can
do so it's very naive code it's
basically just switching
on this log-level enumeration type
and going through linearly
doing basically if it's a type name of
that string
and if we don't find any we return now
so that it's
on par with
enum.getname
a little bit of a benchmark
there it is and here we see the
difference so at first we have the
generated method which is 1.6
nanoseconds and has a zero allocation
and the two string
which involves reflection and the binary
lookup
binary lookup
is 25 nanoseconds and also involves a
bit of
uh allocation which is pretty much the
enemy of every high performance app
right now
so how does generator look like
we have here the type as we've seen the
wi-fi source generator
has the generator attribute on top
and at first there is an initialize
method in the initialize we now can set
up the syntax receiver so basically
initially the syntax receiver now the
syntax receiver is the isomtrix receiver
type
which now visits at each and every
syntax node in the compilation and they
basically do this since uh on visit
twitter note is called a lot of times if
we have if i have a
small
50 lines of code programmed then i have
like 500 invocations of this per
compilation which is also per key press
so we need to mine performance here a
lot don't do any expensive stuff we we
see source generators there is no async
method to to not invite you to to do
something slower this must be fast
otherwise the experience in the tooling
would suffer
and
so
when if you have done watson you will be
familiar with with the uh the syntax
nodes and the expression types
we basically search and
we now search a special method
it has one argument
and it's it has a special name so we'll
search this method and then put it
in the list
this invocations list
and this invocations list
is then used
by the execute method so the execute
method is only this one once
we we grab the syntax receiver
i also check if it's actually c sharp
because i'm producing c sharp code this
would uh fail if this would be a visual
basic project
we get the syntax receiver
and now in this method
i get all the all the symbols so i
so i can actually get the
the type behind that enum so that i can
produce that i know the the the names of
the constants
i also get the options
this is basically some additional files
i can i can get
ms build properties or global analyzer
entries similar to editor config
and then eventually we can generate the
source code
i like to use an
indented text writer because it um
nicely supports indentation so i can i
can create a nice looking c sharp file
so that it's actually reasonable
readable i always like to put auto
generator on top so that automatic tools
such as
other analyzers or maybe source
code coverage shouldn't pick this up
then
it's important to mind compatibility
massage generator could create c sharp
10 code but if a
if if i see if i if our dot standard
project which is by default c-sharp 7.3
would consume it compilation would fail
we would get all the warnings that this
feature is not available in c sharp 3.8
we must increase the language version
and to
to
enable a more
broader consumer range depends on your
scenario you may want to support
multiple or lower languages i did
definitely overdid it here this example
is supporting up to uh c sharp two
but
find five find a good balance you could
also say okay i don't need the latest
features i just write c sharp 7.3 since
this is a good range
it depends on the scenario
then basically generating going
generally really this is all c sharp
code adding up
and eventually
then we will call
from this context
the add source method and this is
actually adding the string that we
assembled
to the compilation we also pass a hint
name
i
always add a dot g dot cs
because this is also a signal that this
is generated code and tools shouldn't
shouldn't pick this up with user code
and then pass it to source context and
then it appears
uh in visual studio we can actually so
basically we can f12 this this is also
the very same experience in wider this
enum input is generated in wider we can
also go to the definition then we see
this
and
we can also have a look here in the
analyzer yes in the analyzers tab
we now see all of the analyzers
generators are analyzers so they will
show up here as well
and we now see
that this
project has actually three analyzers
and if i expand this one we see this is
the enum info.g.t.s which gets um
emitted so this is how i can browse the
the generated code if there is any if a
generator doesn't generate anything then
there is a little bit of an info saying
that this generator doesn't produce
anything to the compilation
also i want to mention testing
so microsoft has released a testing
package
which is microsoft dot code analysis dot
c dot source generators dot testing and
then there is also ms test
and end unit
depends on what you would you prefer
and we can write unit tests and they are
basically string comparison
since the compiler is a
string in compilation out
we convert this combination back to a
string so that we can nicely compare it
so
let me find a
smaller test
for example here basically have here
some some usages of the code it's just a
string as input is basically what the
compiler actually gets as input
and then
what i expect to be the output so i pass
in the
input code the expected output code
i can also optionally add diagnostics
and can also this is not very similar
um if you have tested um
uh diagnostic analyzers it's very
similar with with um
with that so we can say okay this should
produce this warning and so on at this
location
speaking of analyzers now i want to show
you how we can actually produce a
warning so if i would use this analyzer
artist this generator sorry
wrong for example
actually passing in
the lock level sn enum type
since this generator is always also
generating this
stub it's all it's always throwing but i
um it's generated so that we have in the
beginning some
intellisense so that this method is
discoverable
but it shouldn't be called because
um you know we would need then now we
have no type information now we would
need reflection to actually go to the
properties so this is not fast
um and if i would use this now i should
get the error list
okay too many warnings i was expecting
one
let me quickly rebuild
okay uh
sorry about that um
we would see uh one warning
but let me show you the code
so this is how we can
define the diagnostic diagnostic always
has an id it has a message as a verity
this is your default severity because
the user can change the severity either
to a more severe or less severe via an
editor config or global analyzer setting
and
in the code then we
can basically call report
diagnostic
so the report diagnostic method
um
yes
so
we can we can also supply the location
so that the user knows where this error
is and then we report this
this diagnostic which is very very
similar as we would do with a diagnostic
analyzer
i would not like to i'm not sure i guess
this demo would fail i'm afraid i'm not
sure what's
uh what's wrong but i want to show you
the source either way
so we can have
for example a global config so this is a
file called dot global config if it has
another name we need to set an endless
build property but the dot global config
is picked up automatically
and for example here
it must have that is global is true
and then we can set some string so this
is a setting that that i defined by the
generator generally is aware of that i
set it to true which now actually
changes the default behavior
so that if the constant is not found we
don't return null but we actually throw
so in this project where i enabled this
if i go to the same method
we have enough info.get name
if i have to have this now it's actually
different source code generated so if we
fall through to the default we don't
return null
we actually throw an exception
and then with the return type is not
nullable string this would throw and
the generator
can
read this
via actually let me
search the stream
via the analyzer config options so we
can say we had a generator execution
context that we get in in the execute
method we can say dot
analyzer config options we can get the
global options where now this setting is
in
and we read it and we see if the string
is true or false and this can then
control the analyzer another way how we
can control are the analyzer the the
generator another way how we can control
the generator could be custom attributes
that i apply
yes
so that's the the basic about
uh generators
now i want to
[Music]
uh those are the tools i use them all
the time when i do anything before slim
they're super helpful first off sharp
lap
but sharp lip is super for everything
oops i wanted to hit
yes
so usually we can view here the
decompiled code
or the lowered code to be more precise
but we can also
change the view to the syntax tree
and now
we see the worst line representation of
our source code
so this here
it's a compilation unit
it has on top it's called a using
directive this using directive has the
node name
then we have a class declaration the
class declaration has a public keyword
as
as modifier
it also contains one or many method
declarations one of the state method
declarations now for example has the
return type predefined type which is the
void keyword this is how the tree looks
like this is how
we can analyze all the syntax nodes and
see if you're not sure what i'm
searching
for example if we would like to have
every method which returns void if we
want the analyzer
cares about that we could search for
each and every method declaration where
the return type is the predefined type
void
so sharp lab is super handy
also visual studio has something very
similar built in if we enable it in the
installer the installer there is
in the sdk you can enable
the.net compiler platform sdk
and then you get
the syntax visualizer and this is pretty
much
the same as shoplift does if i go to any
code
sometimes it doesn't display then you
need to edit the source and then it
works again
of course it does not know
yes there it is
and here again we see the entire from
this source file one source for this one
compilation unit and we can inspect the
tree
and we also see the trivial trivia is
white spacing and spaces which
have more visual meaning than physical
meaning
there is also the rustling quota
so
this is more useful if you would build a
code
called completion
but
i can't i can put in any code public
void
method
and it's empty and if i generate now we
get the codes that we would need in
order to
build this tree ourself
so watson is basically doing something
similar analyzing it creating tree
and
justice there is dot
dot
source.net
there is um
source whistling dot io which is
basically the same
as the reference source for the net
but but for wasteland for example we can
browse here the
i
source
generator
and also if we go to web access then
actually jump to the source code on
github
where was i
yes
debugging yes finally
sir the attack is ready
um
debugging is not
super
straightforward just as any other
um library especially in visual studio
we just studio loads analyzers at
startup
so this is what we need to tell visual
studio and the tooling
um how to deal with that so we need the
is wasn't component set to true
we can optionally
also emit the generated files
and put in a path where to view them
that we actually see the files generated
but usually the generator does not
generate physical files you will never
see those files
unless you enable this this switch
then we must define a launch profile
with the debug rustling component
i think this is available since visual
studios 16.10 11 something i may mix it
up
then
target a project that you want one so
which would actually produce the source
for this generator
and
we
need to include this generator of course
in the in the consuming project
and must set the ref
the output type to analyzer
and in this case also the set target
framework to not destroy 2.0 uh wasn't
an uh was an analyzer and source traders
must always be dotnet standard 2.0
because it still needs to work for
visual studio which is dotnet framework
so we can't go higher however i do
multi-targeting here for some benefits
which i will show so we need to define
this here
and when we set this up
we can now
actually
go
to example
we can set now the analyzer which is
actually just a library a startup
project
now i set a breakpoint
let's set up breakpoint
yeah
for example have a look at the
at the pass option what they are
this is one way of how to enter
debugging
what i prefer is debugging for my unit
test because it's super precise i only
have the code that i want and i can with
multiple tests so
debugging from a unit test works just as
well
another reference types i mentioned this
a social must be dot-net standard 2.0
standard 2.0 if we have a look at the
language versions
but default
has uses c-sharp 7.3 we could set the
lang version ourselves to a higher
version to have more features not all of
them will work
especially those
which need which need type support such
as the init keyword that needs actually
the
easy external init type if it's not
available for example dr stana the type
is not available it wouldn't work
and
features which actually need one-time
support
i believe
cover-event return types need one-time
support so this will never run on
anything which implements just open
channel 2.0
um but still
for nullable reference types if you want
to have these annotations in order to
know what is null to avoid null
reference exceptions because
they are
tougher to debug in in an analyzer and
then analyze the generators
um we can multi-target
so actually
multi-targeted we've talked standard 2.0
and dot-net
uh
6.0
because the pcl is annotated since was
fully almost fully annotated with dotnet
five and with dotnet six i think it's
fully annotated
um if not then it's super close so we
have all the nullable annotations
everywhere
and
if you want to produce a package it must
be dotnet 2.0 we can't have have
multi-targeting with an analyzer
so
we will set the
where is it
it's here
so we set the
um we only pack
no one line sorry
uh let me break this yes
so we only pack the
dotted standard 2.0
into the package
and this is the location in the package
where
a
analyzer must be
and now we can actually have if i go i
definitely have somewhere question mark
no that's a
value type
where is for example yes here for
example
i actually have a
malleable reference type here and i get
these annotations because of
multi-targeting with dotnet uh six but
we've thought that but standard 2.0 is
not aware of this annotation so we would
get we would get warnings so for docker
standard 2.1 2.0 we have to suppress
these warnings and we can do this with
this ms built property
if it is total channel 2.0
we suppress no warn all the nullable
warnings
and
we may also want to use this package
since
two of the nullable attributes actually
emitted by the compiler but most of them
are not for example
allow null or disallow null
and but we can get them either we can
define them ourself or we use this
package which introduced them for
platforms which do not support them yet
we could also have a source generator
creating them if we have time i'll show
it at the end
now about versioning so
so far we checked out wasling 3.8
which is shipped with the net sdk with
the first dotnet uh sdk it's supported
by visual studio 16.8
and
wider supports c-sharp
nine since
2020.3
now in the next version 3.9 there was
one feature added
i really want to show this to you
it's here so here i now have a 3.9
uh source generator
and this generate then now has a method
called register
for post initialization
and in this post energization method
which is here
i can also add a source but
unconditionally at this time i don't
have the syntax tree available so i
can't really analyze the user code and
build something
from that
i can only
add something unconditionally for
example a stop method for
for for intellisense support um
and this now is actually visible to
later generator phases
in this generator or the next generator
i
have some code down there we can
actually get
the compilation
get this type that we produced
post initialization dot was length 3 on
the square 9 is exactly the type that we
produce up here
and this won't be null so this is
actually available
and the second change is we can have an
enhanced
um context receiver so this context
receiver has
the node just as the other context
receiver had but additionally the
semantic model in case you need in the
syntax receiver already semantic model
but
yeah we shouldn't we should never do too
expensive stuff with this in the in the
syntax receiver because it's called a
lot of times actually i'm not going to
show you how often this is called
so for this example
i have
um
50 lines of code roughly
if i go to the output of this 3.9
generator
oops wrong file generated there it is
so we visited actually 386 notes
and we will also see i can put this uh
down below and while i edit
we will see this change
and more notes get added so really with
almost every key press this is all
executed
and if we would have a
big solution many many projects a lot of
source code so a lot of nodes to put
there what analyzer would be slow than
visual studio or wider would also slow
down because
we need to compile this a lot of a lot
of code and this actually now
performance problem that potentially
the three point
uh
3.8 and above wesleyan
generators have
so now we've gotten at six we got an
addition
we now have incremental source
generators
which are bound to avoid this
problem so here i actually have
this this project which produces
incremental
and this generator
does
create the external
init generators so for example let me
just show the example this should make
things clearer
um
i have here a record
and a record
in
the
emits in the in the primary constructor
those are those are created as init only
properties
but init only properties require the
init keyword and the init keyword
requires
there is external init
type it must be available
so
when i when i step into this we see okay
this type is actually from
system.onetime so it's from the pcl
because 1.6
but if we switch to a lower.net version
for example i now switch to net core app
3.1
this was a c-sharp 8
and so the inner keyboard didn't exist
this type didn't exist
although i have the latest language
version i'm still using g-sharp 10
so
records work but
this type wouldn't isn't there so we now
should actually get a compiler error but
we have a
generator in place
which creates this and now we see i
stepped into this this is not the one
from the bcl in system.onetime this is
actually the
type that that the generator emitted and
this emitted by an incremental generator
so the programming model with
incremental generalism
are different there is only an
initialized method
this syntax receiver is gone because
this was most times the source of
performance issues
and we do create
we can create the equivalent to the
syntax receiver is we can create a
syntax provider which takes two methods
first a predicate which is there to
filter candidates that we're interested
in
and the second one is a transform method
where we can
transform it to a different
type
so if i jump to the to the predicate the
filter
now this is very similar we get in the
syntax node
this is now again called for every
syntax node that we have but only if
there are uh subsequent so with
incremental source changes we we build a
pipeline
and
of um later steps in this pipeline are
only executed if
if a step above actually produces a
different output so if there is a change
then later steps will be executed if
there is no change the cached output
will be reused so we save
work and the experience in the editor is
actually then getting better because
microsoft actually had this issue with
uh 3.9 generators and above
um with the syntax receiver
in the big pci solution the the
experience wasn't wasn't good because
there was so much going on and
typing felt sluggish
so they now using incremental source
generators in the wasteland 4.0
version
and
this is how the
pipeline is is built
and
once we have
um created the syntax provider we now
return we get incremental value
providers so this is not an incremental
step so we now define the first step of
the pipeline and now we can
do the next step for example in our case
now the next step is to
combine
these types so what are we actually
searching um we are searching for
for for our um
declaration as a way searching for every
for for record declarations every record
type which actually has a parameter list
or has parameters in the parameter list
which means there are definitely
properties emitted which require the
init only keyword
or if we explicitly use the init
keyword in code so we find all the all
the accessor declaration syntax which is
basically the thing in brackets
the property and we search for the init
keyword
and those those are then filtered out
and
um
and then uh transformed so in our case
we're not really interested in the type
itself we just need to know if it's a
rare so our transform doesn't really do
anything but we could here return uh
something else as well maybe we would
need an int so the pipeline now now gets
passed further down the later steps and
now we have those uh those syntax nodes
and we can now collect them so this will
now actually run this pipeline step and
combine it with the compilation provider
because we also require the compilation
uh to check if this type is already
there so we can ask the compilation hey
is there already
is
external init type because if there
isn't
i need to create it if there is i would
create a duplicate of the same namespace
and this would cause a warning
so
um
we can check here
do we actually have this type in the
compilation
and if we have not
then we actually add the source
and
um with this pipelines we it we can
really build a very complex uh pipelines
so
this context has
has many um
switches
so we can get the compilation we can get
the pass options the path options for
example contain which language version
this project was was built in
we can get additional texts such as
app settings or some text file if i add
a compilation to a text file we could
build a transpiler so i can just pass in
let's say visual basic code
as a text file in additional code and
then produce c sharp code out of that or
yeah this is how we could build
transpilers
again the analyzer config options that
we can use to read from the global
analyzers or also misbuild properties
it's also possible
and
metadata references there as well so
this is all accessible via previous
generators as well but now we have this
more pipelining syntax and if you have a
look at this incremental values provider
they have
they have link like um
extensions there's a select
aware method where we can apply
more filters or transforms to this
pipeline but this is it isn't linked
actually it's
it's a separate
extensions type it's just link like
and
with incremental source generators we
can now speed up the performance
actually if we do if we do a if it's
only a single compiler.net build
uh then the experience is that there is
not really a difference but if we edit
live in for example visual studio which
which compiles all the time when we when
we type
this could speed up
the experience
and yeah so those incremental source
changes they are available since
wasn't 4.0 but what we need to be
careful
they are only supported in dotnet 6 sdk
so if i would
have a generator which
requires version 4
but would be consumed from a
project which uses the net 5 sdk it
wouldn't work the generator wouldn't
work because those types are unknown
so again we need to find a bit of a
balance
we could say that well
i think that
the net sdk pretty much goes um i think
in
may
out of out of support so maybe go to the
to the viewers immediately
if you require the performance booster
yes we talked about performance
one thing i will show is how does this
look like in
nougat
um
[Music]
so we will have a
we can open this here and look at patch
explorer so nougat package is basically
just a zip file in a special specific
format
and
we see
this is the folder structure it must be
here it must be in analyzers.net
cs for the sharp and there lies our
analyzer
oh
yes
and we also want to
set development dependencies to true for
this package so that by default
[Music]
we get the private assets
tag so that we don't want our analyzers
or our generators in that case to
transitively
so that the consumer is transitively
depending on those
uh we went through plenty of examples i
listed here for interested the slides is
all online
um
some the awesome was then has like a
bunch of uh generators for example
there's also the community toolkit
which um has a
i notified property changed
uh generator
it's
somewhere in here
so we don't need to manually implement
our
uh i not changed all the time
if you would like to know more i listed
here
uh some videos of other speakers about
source generators
and also some links i would like to
highlight this one since it connects a
little bit to the keynote
there is an article about supply chain
attacks
how
social readers could be used maliciously
now
if we would have a malicious nougat
package it can
only under equals only one bad code but
a generator could analyze my source code
so it has full access to the user source
code maybe extract secrets or something
else from there which may not be
actually admitted to the compilation
because it's additional files which i
ignored so this
also opens
more
yeah it's a bit of a danger so
just as with any nougat package we
should only consume trusted sources
and
with that
i would like to know
if i have opened up some questions or
left some questions unanswered
are there any reasons not to always use
the incremental generator or
feels like it's just a more performant
version or did i misunderstand
so um if we should if understand
correctly um if we if we actually should
only use the the incremental source
generator and not the regular uh source
generator um
i i found it more easy i i find the the
regular generators more easy um to to
understand i still haven't fully
understood the source or the
incremental swatches that are really new
so perhaps as a starting point um the
regular
other the three point eight was three
point nine social just maybe a little
bit more easier and when you when you
understand the model in the system then
for production for production project
which may be consumed in a big project
then incremental source channels would
be would be the way to go when you can
when you can safely assume that
everybody will be having everybody who
wants to consume this will have the.6
sdk
external text files
so how could we
analyze in our generator any text file
and
have it have it produce to the code so
we could
let me jump to the
so
i just add any file
so i of course want to make it a text
file
we need to make it part of the
compilation just
only only the dot net sdk by default
picks up c sharp files
we need to make the compiler aware of it
so
i'm actually not entirely sure now i
believe it's is it content believe it's
content okay
not entirely sure but we need to set
some some build action so that it gets
picked up
and then it would appear for example
either in the incremental source
generator
it would appear in the additional texts
provider
so and for the additional text provider
we
basically have source text so the sort
of
with c sharp code we get
syntax nodes
but with with regular text we get a
source text and this is basically a
wrapper around around a string
so this is how we can access a string
with more information and then we can
basically pass this string
manually and produce whatever sharp code
that we like
[Music]
uh no
no you have to build it yourself but you
could build your own transparent nodes
i i believe there is uh in involved i'm
sure that somebody already built some
some out of some specific text format a
a c source generator but
i'm currently not aware of some but
there is no
built-in there is nothing there already
only only with c sharp you get this
get this get the syntax notes
uh do i miss another question or oh yes
um
which use cases
um so when i when i have some when i
have implementations
when i know when i when i know in
advance what implementation would look
like
then the source generator could then i
could automate this via source generator
so i didn't need to manually implement
it all the time which is error-prone
or if i
if i if i have some code with
with reflection i cannot eliminate every
reflection code but it's definitely
subject to maybe replaceable by a source
generator for example
i could if i build my own cli
command library which which searches for
types of a certain command type
um
usually we'll do this via reflection
find all those types in the assembly
which which
are deriving from from that type or are
assignable to
this type but
with a source generator we could analyze
it at compile time and then directly
link it up in source so we don't need
the reflection part so okay compilation
now is a little bit slower but one time
is significantly faster
did i did i answer the question
if not then perhaps
we can talk later or
via
twitter and i believe we are on time
so
i want to thank you everybody for coming
i hope i you learned i was able to to to
to share my knowledges too syntac
and
thank you for staying awhile and
listening have a great conference
you